for decades families across the UK have
sought to prove that a drug called prema
dass caused their deformities it was
prescribed as a pregnancy test in 1960s
and 70s until this warning appeared on
the packet in 1975 that it shouldn't be
used by pregnant women the dog stopped
being sold in 1978 but manufacturers
said evidence that it caused
malformations was inconclusive but now
one of the UK's leading professors of
evidence-based medicine Karl Hennigan
says by collating the data from previous
studies his team at Oxford University
has found a link what the evidence
showed across all them stories is the
first thing is to say the direction of
effect was showing that there was an
association with congenital
malformations but when we actually then
synthesized them into the meta-analysis
the evidence was clearer for this
association and it was a clear
association for all congenital
malformations but also more specific
malformations cardiac malformations
musculoskeletal neurological and
urogenital malformations it was all
clear there is an association there that
is significant this comes almost exactly
a year on from a report by regulators
the MHRA that said a strong link
couldn't be found Sky News discovered
inconsistencies and emissions in this
report for example this forest graph had
been removed anything above the line
points towards an association between
the drug and malformations eight of the
twelve most significant human studies
did just that
Karl Hennigan scientifically pulled the
data from these studies to create an
even more reliable reading the diamond
shape is the correlation of everything
and it sits firmly above the line what's
gone clearly wrong here is complete
failure to do the right approach to
systematic review he asked a clear
question you find all the event of
evidence appraised the quality and
summarize it that was missing in the ewg
report in a statement the MHRA said
their report was robust and independent
that this publication does not contain
new data it is a different approach to
the analysis of the existing historical
observational data which was reviewed in
line with our commitment to review any
new
evidence we will be consulting
independent scientific experts for their
views but here's another revelation
about the drug and it comes from a
former employee of the manufacturer
sheering Sandra Malcolm worked as a
receptionist and had missed her period
she went to see one of the company
doctors to see if she could get a test
with primatives he said I can't give it
to you because it may not work and it
may cause deformities so this was a
sheering doctor yes
saying to you this drug could deform a
child if you're pregnant yes and you
just thought okay I'll stay away from
that drug then yes and I just assumed it
wasn't on the market it couldn't
possibly be on the market this was 1971
the same year over 200,000 women in the
UK used primitive it would be another
seven years before it was removed from
the market shearing is now owned by
German pharmaceutical giant bear who say
that based on available data scientific
evidence does not support an association
between primitives and malformations
Jason Farrell Sky News